1800 dead 53,000 emergency room injuries
1,500 completely collapsed buildings
300,000 buildings right back after the
earthquake this apartment over to drop
down 12 disruptions with the water
system that's gonna take six months to
get water back into all the homes
complete shutdown at the electric grid
and buyers triggered by the event that
will get out of control there will be so
many fires we won't have enough capacity
to buy her we're here to talk about the
big one my name is Lucy Jones and I'm a
seismologist two studies natural
disasters and their impact on people
[Music]
know earthquakes aren't predictable if
somebody tells you they know an
earthquake is coming they aren't using
science to do it and as far as we can
tell it's a random distribution every
year has about the same probability so
we don't know which ones next for
instance the San Andreas here in
California any point on the fault it's
usually about a hundred to 150 years
between earthquakes but that doesn't
mean every hundred and fifty years we'd
get an earthquake it means every year
has about a 1% chance of having the
earthquake at this point we have not
been able to find anything different
about how a magnitude one begins or how
a magnitude seven begins they seem to
begin in the same way so for prediction
to ever be possible there has to be
information in the earth about how big
an earthquake will be before it begins
and the data is looking like the
magnitude is determined dynamically
during the event which means the earth
does not have that information before it
begins it's not the solution
the question of whether earthquake
prediction will ever be possible is
hotly debated I think I'm coming down on
the it's theoretically impossible side
earthquakes really are fundamentally
random and just about all the crazy
stuff comes from people trying to make a
pattern my dog really does know they
must happen in the early morning
this is earthquake weather every one of
those is a desire to make a pattern and
what's fundamentally random animals do
not know any better than we do when an
earthquake is coming they do sometimes
feel the beginning of the earthquake
before we less sensitive humans feel the
strongest part earthquakes have P and S
waves the S wave is the ground moving
this way and the P wave is the ground
moving this way both of them get
generated by slipping on the fault but
they then travel out at different speeds
in an earthquake the S waves are always
larger and do most of the damage and the
P waves always travel faster we have
found that animals are sometimes more
perceptive about the P wave the time
between P and S wave increases is five
miles per second from the earthquake so
if you're 15 miles away from the
earthquake there will be three seconds
between the waves the animal feels the P
wave jumps up and reacts three seconds
later you feel the S wave you think oh
he knew what was coming we want a
pattern we tend to see it and that one
piece of reality that's a few seconds
warning turns into a belief that they
can do it over longer time periods and
it's an interesting psychological aspect
of people that we think prediction is
the solution
can you feel that there's many many ways
we could classify earthquakes one of the
breakdowns that we do is saying which
direction the fault moves and so we have
a thrust fault where it dips at an angle
and one side moves up and over the other
then we have a normal fault where it's
dipping again but now the top one moves
down and away so a thrust fault brings
things closer together a normal fault
stretches the mound and then a
strike-slip fault is where they're
vertical and one side just moves past
another every earthquake moves across a
little piece of fault it begins at a
point that's the hypocenter and then it
ruptures down the fault just like if you
were tearing a piece of paper you would
start at one end and tear down rather
than trying to pull the whole thing at
once and if it moves a little distance
then it's a little earthquake if it
keeps on moving it's a larger earthquake
none of those affect what they do to you
the only thing that really matters to a
human being is how big the earthquake is
which is telling you how big a piece of
fault is moving and how close you are to
that piece of fault if the fault is
dipping at an angle maybe it's pretty
close to you straight down residents who
live here say they heard what sounded
like a bomb when the freeway came down
the Northridge earthquake dipped at an
angle under the San Fernando Valley so
everybody in the Western San Fernando
Valley was literally on top of the
earthquake it's only that distance to
the fault that really matters
violence shaken up like an explosion at
one point I was thrown down I think
that's when the two top floors came down
the first
when we have talked about how to make a
building survive earthquakes the
definition has become don't collapse is
if the building absolutely collapses if
we lose the walls the roof comes down
that's very likely to kill you so that's
the definition that the building code
acts for to be usable you need to do
more than not collapse you need to have
enough integrity left in the building
that you can repair it and not worry
about it coming down in the next
aftershock one of the things that I'm
doing at this point is helping people
understand what the building code gives
them and advocating for moving towards a
functional recovery standard a building
that can recover its function after the
earthquake rather than just a life
safety standard you're far more likely
to be murdered in California than die in
an earthquake maybe talking 30 people a
year on average I mean many years
without any and one year with with quite
a few but it's still way below what we
do from traffic accidents are guns or
hamburgers okay and heart attacks in the
biggest earthquakes there are always
fires that are triggered by the event
one study went through and looked at the
rate and causes of fires after previous
earthquakes and came up with an estimate
of how many fires per thousand
households the receive some level of
shaking from that estimate we came up
with sixteen hundred fires large enough
to call the fire department being
triggered by the San Andreas earthquake
in Southern California and of those
twelve hundred would grow beyond the
capacity of one fire engine to respond
we don't have that many fire engines in
Southern California
and our estimate that some of them would
grow and that the losses from the fires
would be comparable to the direct
shaking losses in the original event you
know when you look back in history at
what has happened when you have a really
big earthquake in a dense urban
environment we always see fires you look
back in 1906 in San Francisco or 1923 in
Tokyo and the fires devastated destroy
the cities and the aftermath of the
earthquake the other big issue for
California of course is that we don't
have enough water where our people are
and we have established aqueduct systems
to bring the water to our people there
are four aqueducts feeding Southern
California every one of them crosses the
San Andreas Fault
in the area expected to move in the one
big earthquake Hitachi reservoir coming
into the Bay Area crosses the Hayward
Fault to get into the area in that
region and when we say that an
earthquake happens on a fault that means
that fault moves which means that one
side is now 10 20 30 feet away from the
other depending on exactly how much
motion there is any aqueduct or pipe
crossing that will be broken every road
crossing it will be broken but there are
ways that we could be going in and
strengthening those crossings making
them more resilient I mean how do you
handle a 20-foot offset that requires
some pretty significant engineering but
it's been done before the Alaska
Pipeline cross the Denali Fault when it
was put in the 70s the geologists went
wait a minute that's where the fault is
it's going to be broken
imagine spilling out all of that crude
across the tundra it's an ecologic
disaster and they had to come up with a
solution they built it on sliders and
that earthquake actually did happen in
2002 and the pipeline did not break
there was 18 feet of offset and it
didn't break so we know how to do it
one factor in the water problem is
getting water into our area but then we
have to get the water into our homes and
businesses and that happens through
distribution pipes those are some of the
oldest infrastructure in a city because
the first thing you put in before you
build the buildings they tend to be
brittle for a long time in California we
use what we're called AC pipes very
brittle and cracks up in earthquakes and
then there's sewer lines running the
site then then they crack - and you get
cross contamination and all sorts of
things so the possibility for widespread
disease and contamination is really
significant the cholera in haiti was a
resultant of that structure we have the
potential for cholera typhoid or a lot
of these other diseases coming through
in California when we have a real
disruption to our water system
tsunamis follow some earthquakes the
earth shaking does not make a tsunami it
can make shishun you can get sloshing
thinking about a bathtub if you shake
the bathtub you can get the water moving
back and forth
tsunamis happen when you change the
shape of the sea floor during an
earthquake and therefore if you thought
a big fault that moves up on the sea
floor the water that used to be there
gets pushed out of the way and that's
the tsunami the biggest tsunamis the
type of thing that we have seen in Japan
or in Indonesia only happened when you
move a really big fault you need a
magnitude eight and a half to nine to
create the type of tsunamis that can
cross the Pacific Ocean and do damage on
the other side the only fault capable of
that in the lower 48 is Cascadia
subduction zone from Cape Mendocino up
to British Columbia Alaska also has
these type of subduction faults that can
produce the big earthquakes the 9.2 in
1964 in Alaska created a tsunami that
killed people in California California
the lower part of California we don't
have those really big faults offshore so
we're never going to create those really
big tsunamis I can't predict an
earthquake before it begins but I can
tell you that you will be receiving
shaking very soon because of an
earthquake that is already underway but
the waves haven't gotten to you yet and
we call that concept earthquake early
warning it requires a network of a lot
of stations that can see the earth
moving here if you are right where the
earthquake begins you're the one
providing the information to everybody
else so you don't get a warning it's
limited usefulness but it's real
their go-to right early warning is
really not prediction early warning is
the shakings already begun here's when
it's going to get to you the big things
that we want to do with early warning
are things like bringing an alarm in
every operating room and dentist's
office so they get the drill out of your
mouth so they get the scalpel out of
your chest before they get jerked move
the elevator to the nearest floor and
open the door so you weren't taught when
the electricity goes out for the next
three days when the Great East Japan
earthquake happened magnitude 9 they had
earthquake early warning no trains
derailed because no trained was still
moving when the earthquake came through
because the early warning system was
used to stop all trains across the
northern part of the country many people
are afraid of dying in the earthquake
but we need to be much more worried
about the aftermath than what happens
during the earthquake itself you'll
almost undoubtedly survive the big one
but afterwards we're gonna be dealing
with damaged buildings disrupted
infrastructure lack of potable water
rampaging fires disruption of all of our
businesses and getting through that is
what's going to determine what happens
to our communities earthquake
preparations are a sliding scale
wherever you are there's more you could
do and the more it will cost
you